favorite mistake
so when i was in first grade the
pinnacle of my acting experience was
when i was um the witch of the west
in
um our first grade play
in hindsight i realized i only got that
part because i could read um not because
of my acting abilities um and i
convinced my mom to let me dye my hair
green and she wanted me to do like the
spray-on
die and i convinced her to do like the
wash dye and it didn't come out
for weeks
and so in my like first grade photos
it's
it's tinged green
and it's not
terribly attractive and i look like
really pretty self-conscious because i
know that my hair is still green
and maybe the moral is i should have
listened to my mother which is often the
moral
um
who is your favorite rebel right now
because your books are all about these
women maybe jane goodall who i do write
about in the book just because
she is still out there like fighting for
conservation and fighting to put
communities at the center of their
conservation efforts
and like at any point in time that woman
could have said like i've done enough
what would it take for you to ever run
for president oh wow that's not where i
thought my question was going
um
oh gosh
you know
i i just don't see that in my path right
now um
and yet i do think it's important that
for any of us who care about
our country who care about our world
to constantly be asking ourselves like
should we run for public office
because there are tens of thousands of
elected public offices in our country
and it matters who's sitting in the
white house as we have certainly seen
recently it also matters who's sitting
in city council on a school board
who's running the local sanitation
commission
like all of these things really matter
and so
for me
like writing advocating
my podcast using my platform in ways
especially during women's history month
to lift up and celebrate women
is what feels kind of right and good for
me
but i don't know if that's always going
to be the answer
but right now i feel
well represented and well purposed in
other ways
well
i don't know anyone who has as much
grace as you do i mean you have really
just lived a life and
been a very admirable person the whole
time and i really
respect that well
i try i don't always get it right
but i always try
persist
and you can hear more from chelsea on
her amazing podcast called in fact with
chelsea clinton and you can pick up the
latest in her glorious series she
persisted in science which is in stores
now and it's phenomenal such as you
thank you thank you chelsea we'll be
right back
[Music]